Tomatenpflanzen pflanzt man anders als
andere Gemüse deswegen passt mal gut auf
hier kommt die Anleitung als erstes muss
ein 20 Liter Topf her das ist ein ganz
schöner Oschi ist aber wichtig damit die
Pflanzen groß und stark werden und weil
es ohne den richtigen Dünger ziemlich
schwierig wird mit dem großen stark
werden Teile ich jetzt meine geheime
Dünger Mischung mit euch das sind zu
gleichen Teilen Urgesteinsmehl und
Hornspäne in Topf jetzt zu einem Drittel
mit torfreier Bio gemüseerde füllen und
dann gebe ich drei Esslöffel von der
Dünger Mischung dazu lockere den Ballen
der Pflanze ein bisschen auf und dann
entferne ich die unteren Blätter
ungefähr so und Pflanze die Pflanze
möglichst tief ein es ist also jetzt
viel mehr Stängel unter der Erde als
noch vorher im kleinen Töpfchen und so
bildet die Pflanze viel mehr neue
Wurzeln aus und steht stabiler die würde
trotzdem umkippen wenn sie keinen Stab
hätte das ist also ganz wichtig und dann
stellt die einen möglichst sonnigen und
am besten überdachten und angießen und
folgt uns wenn Ihr wissen wollt wie es
in den nächsten Wochen mit euren Tomaten
weiter